hey we've got merch again and new merch
and there's more coming soon don't tell
anyone
go to slowmoguys.shop
links in the description
hello there i'm gav welcome to the
slow-mo guys video all about how a
pinball machine works firstly i want to
say thanks to jersey jack pinball for
providing the machine for this video
it's a willy wonka machine it's very
nice very colorful i've been fascinated
by pinball for quite a long time i was
introduced to a real pinball machine by
a canadian man named ed before that my
entire experience with pinball was the
significant percentage of my childhood
taken up by this
and even though we live in the future
now well beyond the days of
electromechanical scoring the actual
playfield itself
uses components unchanged for decades
it's still very mechanical and not only
that very fast moving so why don't we
whip out the phantom and play a little
game of pinball since i got this machine
i've played a lot of wonka pinball and
i've determined some areas of the
playfield that i want to feature but
it's going to be an extremely fiddly job
so i've got the flex 4k with the probe
lens on and i'm going to use that with
this extremely bright light
to to really get in there
okay the glass is off i think we should
start with me just playing a cheeky game
of pinball just you can see everything
that moves and then we'll get in there
for the slo-mo replays the game is fully
functional without the glass and now
there's no glare for filming however i'm
slightly worried about taking a pinball
to the chin because they do go flying
in multiball especially and also without
the glass something that i wasn't
expecting this machine is now incredibly
loud there's a i guess a huge sound
dampening effect with the glass cover so
get ready for some clangs and clunks
i'm not sure if you knew this about me
but i'm actually phenomenal at pinball
i'm really good at from this flipper
hitting it so that it bounces off this
target here
and
drains about 165 miles an hour that's
probably my specialty all right high
score coming up
in all seriousness i'm a total pinball
novice so apologies in advance for my
sorry display of skills and
potential incorrect terminology
starting with a gobstopper if you hit it
once it will spin around revealing a
hole and then you can hit a ball in
locking it for multiball it's actually a
virtual lock it's not keeping the balls
physically it pops them back out into
the shooter lane
just there but one of the ways to build
multiballs is to activate various locks
now we're in the pot bumpers at the top
i'm sure you've seen these on a pinball
machine extremely fast moving extremely
loud down here if the pink light is lit
the kickback will prevent the ball from
draining on the outer lane there when
it's not lit you lose the ball locked
another ball for multiple there in the
gobstopper when the yellow light in the
center middle is lit the ball will be
diverted from the gobstopper ramp down
onto a magnet to be hit through the
spinner and when the super lock light is
lit that will lock a ball for the one
curvature multiball which as this
machine is the standard version is a
virtual lock on the limited edition
collectors edition this is a physical
lock that sits at the back there and it
will physically store your balls before
dumping them back onto the playfield as
you can see now i'm in what i like to
call slingshot hell where my ball is
just bouncing back and forth between the
slingshots finally gain control started
gobstopper multiball locked three balls
and all three are now auto plunged back
onto the playfield multiball still
freaks me out even if i know what i'm
supposed to be aiming at just the fact
that there's so many balls in the
playfield and you still have to keep
your eye on
when a ball is about to hit the upper
flippers and the lower flippers it's a
lot to look at and it didn't help here
that i actually started a second
multi-ball the kid multi-ball within the
gobstopper multi-ball which caused all
six balls to be on the playfield at the
same time
there's a lot going on this is actually
a a montage of
several different moments from the same
play session
but there are bits cut just to show
different stuff happening a lot quicker
so we can get to the slow motion
if you get the high score when you
submit your name it'll take a picture of
your face and you'll hear a little thunk
inside the machine which we'll get to
later
to fully show how this machine works i'm
going to need to film underneath the
playfield and thankfully you can just
pull it out like this and everything is
still fully functional i can activate
pretty much everything you're also able
to push it up fully the most common way
for something to move on the pinball
machine is through switches and
solenoids you can see a few of them here
uh this empty gap in the bottom left
that's where the the wonkavator ball
lock would be if i had that version of
the game a solenoid is basically very
tightly coiled wire which when a current
passes through will create a magnetic
field pulling the metal rod through the
center this one is the flipper and this
one is the vertical up kicker in the
ball trough responsible for deploying
balls and they work very quickly so why
don't we get straight into slow mo
starting with the vertical up kicker of
the ball trough pressing the start
button hits this switch which activates
the vertical up kicker in the ball
trough firing a ball straight up
into the shooter lane where it'll roll
down
and it's ready to be plunged
by the plunger
[Music]
on a full plunge the ball will go right
round the top straight into the pot
bumpers this was the part of the machine
i was most excited to see just because
the ball so quickly bounces back and
forth between these multiple times per
second you can see the way it works is
when the ball rolls over the white
plastic
the rod connected to the metal ring
above is pulled down
by a solenoid inside so when it rolls
over the white plastic
this leaf switch completes the circuit
activating the solenoid that pulls this
rod down and that is connected to the
ring above on the top of the playfield
and the way the ring is angled causes
the ball to be ejected out from any
angle that it approaches the pop bumper
you can see it's now activating the
switch rod pulls down ball fires back
out
it bounces seriously fast i counted here
that the ball went back and forth eight
times in less than half a second
absolutely insane
now heading down to the flippers classic
area of a pinball machine as you can see
press the button flipper moves hits the
ball away it's a very strong mechanism
and there are actually two circuits
regarding the flipper it's a solenoid
once again
actuating this arm there's a circuit for
the initial high power burst of current
which is needed to move it and then a
separate lower power circuit to hold the
flipper in place if you want to hold it
up just so you're not running high
current through it constantly
the spring will return it to its resting
position when you physically press the
flipper button a little piece of plastic
is pushing against metal leaf switches
inside
when one piece of metal knocks into
another it completes the connection you
may be wondering why is there three you
can actually press just the first one
that activates the lower flipper when
the first piece pushes the second piece
of metal into the third piece the entire
circuit is complete and the upper
flipper goes as well usually both
flippers go at the same time because
you're really smashing those things this
is the slingshot slightly above the
lower flip as you'll notice two leaf
switches sat either side
of this kicker also powered by a
solenoid inside when the ball approaches
from either side of that thing it will
complete the circuit causing the ball to
be kicked out
often straight into the other one which
causes a nice
back and forth between them this is the
gobstopper hole when a ball goes in as i
mentioned before the ball is locked but
it's actually just returned to you
through this plastic channel underneath
and then using another vertical up
kicker
is shot straight back up and that is the
ball that you continue playing with
comes out just slightly higher up the
shooter lane than where the ball starts
originally when multiball starts the
game will just launch balls onto the
playfield for you using the auto plunger
this piece of metal is shaped to come
out either side of the normal plunger
whacking the ball at full speed back up
the shooter lane
[Applause]
when you hit the ball up the gobstopper
ramp the ball can either continue
straight through depending on where you
are in the game or if the yellow light
is lit on the left there once the ball
is detected using the optical sensors
this diverter piece of metal will come
down from the top slowing the ball down
enough
for it to just drop through this hole in
the side if the ball's traveling full
speed it never falls down there the ball
will then fall down
onto a magnet where it's ready to be hit
by the upper left flipper into the
spinner for usually some mad points
because every full rotation
it activates this leaf switch on the
right here so you can see if you hit it
through there and it spins 40 times this
switch will be pressed 40 times which
could mean 41k bars if you've got super
spinner activated now we're into some
multiball i'm honestly so surprised at
how often the ball just leaps into the
air sometimes it will hit the glass when
you're playing up here in the center is
the captive ball which operates exactly
like a newton's cradle you have to hit
the ball hard enough for it to send the
fireball into the target basically just
a target you have to hit pretty high now
one of these balls is going to drain out
of the left outer lane which is the one
that has the kickback which when lit if
the ball rolls over this metal rollover
switch is automatically bashed straight
back out and your ball is saved i spent
a lot of time filming this machine but
one of the most fascinating parts of it
to me was something i noticed when i was
filming the flippers
the ball is rarely hit just once the
first impact
almost stops the flipper and the ball
and then as it catches up it then does a
secondary push or a secondary hit to the
ball and not only that without a ball
the flippers decelerate so fast that it
ripples the rubber away from the plastic
this all occurs in around 0.1 of a
second so incredibly difficult to see
with the naked eye first i thought
something was wrong until i noticed this
behavior on every single flipper even
the upper one here such force the rubber
completely comes away in my quest to
become better at pinball i was learning
about a move called a live catch where
you sort of meet the ball right as it
lands in the flipper and they sort of
both cancel out each other's momentum
it's i guess like the closest to a real
life frame perfect trick that there is
in pinball so i was thinking maybe the
rubber whipping away from the plastic on
the flipper actually extends the
possible window of a live catch because
it's literally extending the flipper
itself and cushioning all around the
ball it's actually not a good example of
a live catch because the ball uh still
just rolled off the flipper usually it's
gonna just stop dead on the flipper and
then you have it caught now let's move
on to the tilt bob it sits inside this
machine on the left as you can see it's
swinging
loosely and it's got a ring surrounding
it so you can see here when i nudged the
machine and gave a little tilt to try
and save the ball it gave me a warning
because it detected that the tilt bob
had hit the ring and it's a big part of
the game to sort of smack the machine
around but if the bob hits the ring
three times you'll get a tilt you'll
lose your current ball and lose your
bonus
finally we have the knocker it sits in
the back box so i've got to take this
part off and it's the thing you hear
when you get high score or if you roll
over the special and it's just a
solenoid with a plastic tip rod that
thumps a piece of mail
incredibly simple
well there we have it i honestly found
that so interesting just shoving the
camera in different spots and learning
how each piece worked just from the
footage alone
found it fascinating i really enjoyed
that one hopefully you enjoyed it too
even if you're not into pinball maybe
you found it interesting anyway big fat
thanks to jersey jack pinball for
supplying this wonderful machine and
honestly supplying me with a new hobby
i've been in here almost every day for
the last month uh just trying to get
into wonka's office haven't done it yet
it's actually
it's an easy game to sort of get going
on but it's a lot deeper than you think
there's actually a ton to do and uh i'm
really just scraping the surface on it
okey dokey thank you very much for
watching this video make sure you share
it with someone who likes pinball and
now i'm going to briefly talk about the
sponsor of this video
this video is sponsored by skill this
video
this video is sponsored by skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes so you can pick up a new skill
or broaden your existing passions if
you're a regular viewer of the slo-mo
guys channel you may be interested in
plenty of topics on skillshare varying
from film and video production to
photography uh entry level and more
advanced skills one skillshare class
that currently interests me is this one
on lighting most of our videos honestly
have been
lit by the sun outdoors and i'm really
interested in learning about different
types of lights in a studio environment
and i feel like
this will be the perfect place to get
that info then i'm probably going to buy
some lights skillshare is learning focus
there's no distractions like ads and
there's new premium classes added all
the time it's less than ten dollars a
month if you choose an annual
subscription and you can get your hands
on it by going into the description of
this video the first 1000 people who
sign up will get a free trial of
skillshare premium membership thank you
very much for watching this video make
sure you subscribe if you like it and
kick the old bell in the face i'll see
you in the next one